a lot of people and i'm wondering why
would you defend rachel kirknell
chris harrison is speaking out i don't
know if i should tell you this
in a sneak preview for his good morning
america appearance airing thursday
harrison says he quote made a mistake
marking the bachelor host's first
interview since taking time off from the
franchise it was a mistake
i made a mistake i am an imperfect man
i made a mistake and i own that this
preview comes after e.t learned new
details about harrison amid the backlash
following his controversial remarks
which has left the 49-year-old reality
host quote
concerned about his job not a good look
not a great move on monday a source told
e.t quote chris and his team
are concerned about this ordeal and the
changes occurring
they're trying to figure out his next
move chris is a hard working guy who
loves his job
this is the final rose tonight in
february harrison released a second
apology for defending rachel for connell
and revealed he would be stepping away
from his bachelor duties for a quote
period of time he added quote i was so
wrong
and felt ashamed as long as there's good
things being discussed
a guest host was announced for the
bachelors after the final rose special
airing next week
with former nfl star emanuel acho
stepping in for harrison
not to pat ourselves on the back but it
really takes you to places in your
emotions you've never been before e.t
spoke with harrison in december about
how the bachelor franchise has been
impacted by social issues
i don't think we you know wag the dog
the dog wags the tail and so
you know i think we're a microcosm of
what's going on out there and obviously
black lives matter
and racial injustices and where that
stands as a he's a huge
topic and so these are topics that are
affecting everybody in the world right
now so yeah it
it should bleed into the pages of the
bachelor and bachelorette and
and so we encourage that